[Music]
you are watching the press preview a
first look at what's on the front pages
as they arrive it's time to see what's
making the headlines with the director
of think tank demos polly mckenzie and
chief political correspondent for the
daily telegraph christopher hope they'll
be with us from now right up until
midnight
so let's see what's on some of those
front pages for you now children set to
be jabbed from early next week reports
the times despite the jcbi's
recommendations against vaccinating 12
to 15 year olds
that's also the lead in the telegraph
the guardian also leading on this story
that ministers are expected to defy
advice from the jcbi
the financial times leads on tech giant
apple's delay on introducing a code that
detects child sex abuse following
concerns for privacy
how could they says the mirror leading
on the secret plans for the queen's
funeral that have been leaked online
the express leads with the same story
adding that the palace is in fury
and the daily star says the uk is set
for weather hotter than benidorm but
don't blink as you might just miss it
i'm joined tonight by polly mckenzie and
christopher hope welcome to you both
good evening let's start with the times
uh and have a look at that story that uh
children set to be jabbed from early
next week and this says despite the
advice from the joint committee on
vaccination and immunization against
those 12 to 15 being vaccinated so the
the government not heeding the advice
polly
well i just want to pick you up on the
details that's not quite what the jcbi
have said they didn't publish a report
saying it was a bad idea
to vaccinate 12 to 15 year olds they
were published in the morning and they
said that they can't they can't
recommend it though haven't they said
exactly but
again and and it is nitpicky i recognize
but it's just on this it's so important
to be so precise because if we're not we
we fuel
uh anti-vaccine conspiracy theories they
haven't recommended against it they've
said they can't recommend it and you
know that's dancing on the head and up
him but it does matter because what they
said is it's finally balanced it's
slightly
the benefits outweigh the risks but
they've only looked at it through a
health lens and what they've said is
that it's outside of their remit to
consider any wider benefits to society
or to children's education from being
vaccinated and therefore they've passed
the decision up the chain to the chief
medical officer chris witte who will now
make a further recommendation to
government so i just think we need to be
really really careful here you're
totally right they have said they can't
recommend it but that's slightly
different from saying they recommend not
doing it they are giving ministers a
real window to say look there are other
considerations and ministers are i think
going to go ahead as is being reported
here in the times and the telegraph with
uh the the support of the chief medical
officer to say that there are wider
benefits if we can keep kids in school
that's a huge benefit not just in in the
immediate term but to their whole life
you know we've had two years of
schooling massively disrupted our kids
what they need most of all is to be in
school to have an uninterrupted year and
i think those considerations are what
the chief medical officer and the
government will be considering yes uh
the committee concluded that it couldn't
recommend mass vaccination of millions
of healthy children since covid is only
a mild illness for the vast majority of
young people um but but many of the
papers uh reporting that the government
i mean some leaks actually saying that
ministers uh have suggested that
actually vaccinations for that age group
will go ahead in in a few days time
christopher
yeah i think that's over egg actually
because um i actually wrote there's a
story in torreira's telegraph so i've
been doing it all day i mean what's
happening here is the jcvi had a very
narrow remit they could just look at the
effect on the 12 to 15 year old cohort
of people they couldn't look any wider
than that they couldn't look at the
effect on teachers who have to teach
these children or the effect of a wider
effect on education and the effect on
mental health and withdrawing children
from school those are the areas
which the four chief medical officers
led by chris whittie are going to look
at and the ministers are hoping that by
middle of next week when you look at the
whole issue in the round
not just the narrow point that polly
said about the 12 to 15 rules they will
then decide that actually on balance
it's better for general public health
that we should get on with this
vaccination i think the times is a bit
toppy on the timing because
um we reveal in tomorrow's telegraph
that actually every single parent will
have to give written confirm
confirmation they approve and give
permission for each vaccination
that can't even start until the um cmos
are reported back probably on wednesday
or thursday so it won't be until the
following week i would imagine at the
earliest when written consent can start
to be granted a lot of paperwork a lot
of red tape and important red tape and
important paperwork before we get this
started but certainly we all think
that's coming
and polly what sort of impact do you
think parental approval will have on the
rollout of this should it should it go
ahead
i think the key part is bureaucratic as
chris says it takes time for schools to
put letters in kids school bags or even
send emails uh you know it's routine
when it comes to flu jabs for example
which are given out in school
environments and certainly the school my
kids are at send out five or six
reminders over the course of the either
run up to the flu vaccine because so
many people
don't immediately get back to them there
will of course be some parents who don't
feel comfortable
getting their kids vaccinated and and i
think
even though you know if you poll the
public in general people are quite
comfortable with the idea of mandating
vaccination i don't think we should go
that far i don't think it actually helps
anybody to be forcing vaccines
especially onto kids they're a kind of
it's an emotive thing or trying to
overrule parents so there will be a
small impact on some parents who say no
some kids some teenagers who may not
wish to be vaccinated of course as well
but the main thing is simply the
paperwork and that of course may mean
that vaccine programs have to last quite
a long time in school if you are
consistently having to to wait to chase
those forms i should say
go ahead
sorry i i i should polly is totally
right and we haven't even got there on
boosters yet we're still waiting for
jcbi to rule and whether we need
boosters for people to top up their
double jabs from earlier this year so
this is the beginning and there was a
map there is frustration that the jcbi
can't get on quicker with than this
and assess the information faster we
appear to be lagging behind
other other comparable countries and
that's not acceptable for a lot of
people in government
let's move on to the times different
subjects and uh social care the headline
there pm to break pension pledge for
overhaul of social care um are people
happy and willing to pay for it polly
well
social care is one of the biggest issues
certainly of my lifetime that has been
unresolved we have had five different
commissions or investigations into what
we should do about social care uh it was
there was nearly a settlement in 2010
which uh george osborne torpedoed by
saying that it was a
death tax that was going to be
implemented the coalition government
in which i served tried to implement
something and then sort of wimped out
gave up on it because it was too
expensive theresa may managed to
completely torch the 2017 general
election campaign with her plan to do
something on social care and boris
johnson promised that he one of the big
things that he would do after winning in
2019 was sought out social care he said
he had a plan ready and waiting to go
and now we know that they're still in
fact hacking out the details of it it's
been controversial because they've gone
back to this idea of a national
insurance rise polls pretty well
uh when you ask people a bit like gordon
brown did back in the you know 30 20 20
years ago to from the nhs but the
problem with national insurance is first
of all conservative manifesto said they
won't put up national insurance but also
it's only paid by working age people and
at least half of the social care budget
goes on elderly people and the asset
protection scheme
they're talking about mainly will
benefit uh older people as well so it
feels a bit unfair for working age
people to pay for the asset protection
of wealthy older people however so
they've got one more uh pledge that
they're going to reverse which
potentially is getting rid of the
pensions triple lock so that pensioners
are at least contributing a little bit
yeah christopher edging
in there
well she says polly rightly says people
are generally quite happy with it but i
wouldn't suggest that uh tori voters are
certainly because of the breach in the
manifesto that was passed in in 2019
what i don't understand is if boris
johnson had this idea ready an oven
ready idea on the stats number 10 in
july 2019 why where then went into an
election five months later saying he
won't increase national insurance if
that was the plan which he's had a plan
let's say he had a plan said out there
in july why fight an election on a
policy he knew he'd have to break unless
he had no plan and the plan has been
probable together since the election and
what he said on the steps of number 10
isn't quite the plan he said he had then
this plan will really annoy tory voters
core voters
as you know pensioners don't pay
national insurance it's a plan written
on the backs of the young and it'll be a
problem i think and it could be a real
disconnect with some of the party's core
voters here and it's going to be quite
difficult isn't it for him polly because
he's going to be breaking two
manifesto commitments not one but uh two
and the suggestion that we might surmise
from what christmas was saying is that
there was no plan to start with
i think chris has uh hit the nail on the
head that of course that wasn't a plan
as far as johnson um but nevertheless
that doesn't mean this isn't a sort of
halfway decent plan it's you know if i
was the prime minister it's not the plan
i would implement but that's kind of
neither here nor there
as i said we've been going up and down
this mountain
for my entire life in our politics and
it's got to stop i don't like this plan
particularly i don't particularly want
young people to pay but if we're worried
about inheritance or we're worried about
asset inequality
we can always do things to address those
elsewhere in the system and you know
chris is completely right the
conservative voters conservative
backbenchers torpedoed an effort by phil
hammond under under tree's major
leadership to make a much smaller change
to national insurance around
self-employed people precisely because
of a another promise not to put up
national insurance it's possible this
will be torpedoed the labour party is
kind of already gearing up to say that
they're against it just as they were
against theresa may's different but
equally sensible plan to put some money
into social care i really think we've
all got to just hold our noses of course
it's an imperfect plan but it'll do and
we can't spend another 40 years waiting
for perfection to come along hold our
noses and get on with it paulie thank
you very much and christopher for the
moment uh stay with us we're going to
take a break coming up this story on the
front of the financial times employers
attempting workers back into the office
with
yoga
and djs would that get you back at work
stay with us to find out
[Music]
welcome back you're watching the press
preview still with me director of think
tank demos polly mckenzie and chief
political correspondent for the daily
telegraph christopher hope welcome back
to you both um let's have a look at the
ft uh and this is um very interesting
the lengths that employers are going to
to get employees back in the office a dj
yoga thousand pound bonus
polly what do you think
uh well i haven't been trying any of
these things to lure my uh 20 or so
demos colleagues back to the office but
maybe that's what i'm doing wrong
um we did
we have improved the quality of the
biscuits and the coffee but i think you
know
we're trying to find the new normal
aren't we we we shifted the default from
everyone has to come to the office every
day to
everyone's at home every day for office
workers which of course we must remember
is only only perhaps 45 percent of the
population even at the peak
weren't traveling to work so it's a you
know it it we have to remember lots of
people this is an irrelevant
conversation but we've been doing some
work at demos on the kind of the policy
implications of that big shift to
flexibility and what we're trying to
establish now is the ground rules of a
of a hybrid model where you do get the
benefits of people being in the office
sometimes but people also get to stay at
home and i think if you know if the if a
bit of the power has shifted to
employees
and employers do you have to make it
worthwhile i think that's probably a
good thing i i predict that as a policy
prediction
djs are not going to last very long
christopher you look as if you're
scoffing at that idea of the power
transferring to the employees
really i mean you know which world is
demos working i mean i think the people
should be glad they got a job it says
this ft article says that um phoenix
group is providing safe safety social
events that you can um have where
lanyards different colored bands saying
i'm keeping my distance i'm okay with
high fives
honestly really i think no bonuses might
be required to solve the hgv should
drive a shortage um get them to get to
get more stuff into our shops but really
in office work i think we should be glad
to mix and blend our working lives maybe
but you know get back to work you don't
need yoga do you djs cash on offer to do
a job to pay for already people what
skylight people in my ear are saying yes
we do yes we do
this is free market economics you're
supposed to be in favor of this
employers and employees negotiate what
works for them and if you know whatever
works for the employers they should try
out in order to get the best out of
their employees i mean it's just you
know and if actually having a bit of fun
or collaboration or making it worthwhile
to travel to work gets the best out of
employees then employers should be
absolutely free to do it and not be told
by chris hope uh to be a stricter and
more austere and less explain that
chris do you want a quick comeback
well i'm not saying be stricter am i i'm
just saying that do we need all these
extra add-ons just let's get back to
work and get the economy going i mean
but perhaps uh perhaps denmark thinks
that
yoga will make you work better i don't
know
we shall see uh let's all get back to
work i mean we've all been working
throughout actually here
some in the studio some at home and it's
worked pretty well but i think hybrid is
is the future polly and christopher
thank you so much for taking us through
the papers this evening we'll see a
little later